en dans la famille du champion de
football neymar il faut croire que le
jeune homme n'est pas le seul à faire
tourner des têtes
il semble que sa maman est elle aussi le
même don si neymar est une icône du
sport il est aussi pour beaucoup un
sex-symbol qui du brésil à la france
fait beaucoup fantasmer un don que le
joueur semble avoir hérité de sa maman
nadine goncalves âgé de 52 ans elle
entretient en ce moment une liaison avec
un mannequin de 22 ans soit six ans plus
jeune que son propre fils une relation
qui au brésil fait beaucoup parler et
qu'elle n'a pas hésité pour autant à
afficher sur les réseaux sociaux si on
sait que son père est très présent dans
la carrière de neymar puisqu'il est son
manager on entendait moins parler de sa
maman une maman dont il est très proche
et histoire de montrer qu'il n'est pas
choqué par cette relation le champion a
tenu a publiquement commenté la
publication de sa mère sur les réseaux
sociaux
soyez heureux je vous aime et vous la
maman de neymar en couple avec un jeune
homme 30 ans plus jeune qu'elle
choqués ou pas choquer alors on va
remettre la photo de la maman de neymar
donc avec tiago ramos donc nadine
goncalves rien qu'on ait deux belles
photos 1 voilà les cherry pour qu'on les
voit bien si vous pouviez en trouvez
merci en régie est ce que ça vous choque
vous cette différence d'âge castaldi a
pas du tout pas du tout d'abord il a
tout du des marsois euros je vous aime
chacun fait ce qu'il veut c'est une
belle relation on n'a pas à juger on n'a
pas à s'en mêler on n'a pas voilà
projetés les choses voilà est très bien
là j'ai un mec je n'y a pas de scandale
30 ans bon ça bouge chez vous mais c'est
pas grave moi ça me choque pas alors il
ya une vidéo sociaux qui fait le buzz
sur twitter c'est une vidéo
tik tok de tiago ramos donc le compagnon
de la maman de neymar et regarder
beaucoup ont du mal à l'imaginer trop de
nouveau beau père de neymar garder
[Musique]
rien
jadore jadore jadore voilà moi j'adore
mathieu qu'est ce que tu dis mon chat
c'est à dire que sur le papier
évidemment c'est pas choquant de te dire
que trente ans de différence que ce soit
garçon fils petits garçons à partir moi
la personne est mineur et majeur par an
est consentante
après ce qui m'ennuie à tout petit peu
sans vouloir être méchant et quand je
vois le gars on sait que j'ai peur que
ce garçon ne soit pas là pour de très
très bonnes raisons
non c'est non l'argent est très célèbre
l r d mais là il a l'air d'aimer d'elle
des mais visiblement la lumière il est
sûr tic toc qui se bougent il a l'air
d'aimer la célébrité voilà je
malheureusement j'ai un mauvais feeling
alors c'est une star sur tik tok
regarder dans un autre style
voilà une autre vidéo au casque ou mono
1,6
[Musique]
choix
alors oui mathieu qu'est ce que tu
disais si la vérité n'est pas dite a
mariage et j'ai peur je mets un
conditionnel ça s'appelle un escort non
aux garçons ils voient bien de chanter
rêve de lumière et maman neymar
forcément sa lumière sa vallée de
l'argens savez de la célébrité
j'ai peur malheureusement et jean
bousquet c'est l'amour passe pour
matthieu delormeau gilles verdez ouvrez
les yeux
quel mépris mathieu quel mépris pour
l'amour
la mère de m a follement amoureuse a
écrit l'inexplicable ne s'explique pas
il se vit elle aime ce garçon innocent
ça j'ai pas de gauche et je n'ai pas
douté dans des sens que j'ai un doute
jean-michel me gilles jean michel maire
yves gille tu salis l'appel et j'en suis
désolé si si la même femme que je
respecte énormément donné un stand de
poissons fumés ou sa poule amazonie il
sera samedi au play vous êtes des
naïvetés mais sont bien sûr sans
s'affoler c'est le finir les enfants je
n'ai pas que je suis résident laisser
l'eau finir oui bah oui sophy cost mais
jean michel tu vis dans un monde de
bisounours tu sais très bien que c'est
un échange de bons procédés
quelles que soient les cités oui voilà
son contraire
non mais ça n'empêche pas l'amour
effectivement de net etc
après c'est vrai que l aile centre avec
un jeune homme qui doit être fougue et
qui doit à lui faire des petits plaisirs
dramatique tu vois et puis oui se
retrouve à faire des vidéos de technique
avec un nombre de followers max et puis
tout le monde est content mais c'est pas
du marketing sophie l'amour c'est pas un
échange de bons procédés pour chacun
gagne quelque chose alors à l'origine à
porte chez nous on parle d'amour avec la
malvie la ville rené rené voit les toits
qu'il connaît bien le foot rené rené est
figé rené est figé on va le garder comme
ça oui ben jama non mais je suis désolé
à ce moment là jean-michel alors toutes
les pertes étaient célèbres jamais dans
leur vie pour en voir quelqu'un donc
voilà de données de sincère avec eux on
est condamné à voir que des gens
intéressés par la célébrité par les
followers parle parle oseille
oui
pourtant julien oui 80 pour moi de vivre
ensemble ouais bah isolé au prendre la
parole quand on vous donne la parole
merci mon jean vinet merci non mais là
oui oui benjamin effectivement lors dans
ces cas là quand on est à la télé on n'a
que des gens intéressés et voilà ces
bosses de deer valley dont il a tu es
poissonnier respectivement oui bah oui
c'est vrai que les sprinteurs avec connu
et ken l'argent qui n'est pas connu
quant à pas mais c'est pas ne pas
résumer ça comme ça c'est pas vrai
wallon et à tous très embêté benjamas et
passez pas votre meilleure intervention
michel aime bien moi je n'en avais je
trouve dégueulasse
l'attitude de mathieu et de jean-michel
ils font un procès en sincérité à ce
garçon et à la mère de naïma tout ça par
pure jalousie parce que vous
n'atteindrez jamais ce niveau d'amour
peut-être j'espère que vous connaîtrez
un jour ils s'aiment et vous leur
retirer le droit d'être heureux
mais franchement vous êtes des vieux
aigris voilà ce que vous êtes thierry
mathieu scud mois excuse moi jle il sen
pardon était ami avec madame neymar
qu'est-ce que tu en sais gré à gré que
le métabolisme mois avec eux et ben moi
j'ai les yeux et tant qu'on ne trouvera
pas l' inverse tout ce que je vois c'est
un jeune garçon qu'est sur instagram et
qui rêvent de célébrité qui est tombée
sur une femme qui forcément à 52 ans a
un peu peur de vieillir et qu'il est et
edward enfin c'est pardon de vous le
dire je vois ça tous les jours à mon
tout petit niveau ça à facebook et je
n'ai rien de te coller donc je laisse
imaginer madame démarre je vais vous
dire de vous dire ce qui se passe sur
twitter ça réagit beaucoup
matthieu delormeau a raison je pense que
ce petit jeunot est là seulement pour le
fric mais bon s'ils sont heureux
ensemble pourquoi pas il fait vraiment
très très jeune quand même un couple
informer sur jean michel maire qu'est ce
que t'en sais jean michel mr tout le
monde n'est pas intéressé pauline ce
serait son père qui aurait une femme de
30 ans de moins personne n'en parlerait
ça la raison pauline ça c'est vrai que
dans le sens inverse personnes en
auraient parlé
mine de rien qu'est ce que vous en
pensez dc raconte jean michel maire
personne n'aurait parlé mais le principe
d'un couple aussi c'est peut-être
parfois dans des chansons c'est plus
facile dans l'autre sens on se marre
voilà ça aurait placé les paroles là la
fed a remis sa casquette de vieux cons
là sans bagarre d'avoir non pas du tout
pas du tout si sophie koch sophie ma
chérie mais non mais je trouve ce que je
voulais souligner c'est l'intelligence
de neymar en tout cas vis-à-vis de sa
maman moi je trouve que je pense qu'elle
apprécie beaucoup son attitude
effectivement de cautionner cette
relation de dire qu'il aime sa maman
qu'il est content pour elle qu ils
aiment leur souhaite du bonheur et ça je
me sens très intelligent niveau
communication et pour sa mère et pour
lui voilà alors on va passer aujourd'hui
j'ai juste avant j'aimerais qu'on voit
le sondage oui gilles verdez mathieu et
jean michel c'est vraiment les vieux
dans leur tête
l'amour n'a plus d'âge la société a
évolué on peut être avec des gens de
n'importe quel âge du moment de vous
être heureux ça a plus de couleurs vous
êtes mais vous et les autres descendent
vers djelfa vive et l'amour jjl heureux
comme si vous être heureux c'est pas
éclater si vous être heureux pardon
cyril gilles on parle pas des
différences d'âge effectivement il
serait pas connu tous les deux se
seraient rencontrés n'importe où dans
n'importe quel but il serait comptable
est ce que caissière géré a aucun
problème là on dit juste que on n'est
pas fous on voit un garçon sur instagram
qui est beau gosse est mignon qui rêvent
de lumière et comme par hasard et ça
avait quand même des marques à 50 ans
avec les richissimes of arrêté cinq
autres qui n'ont pas compris que tout ça
effectivement s'étaient intéressées sont
vraiment débile moi je vais citer mais
pour clore le débat
la mère de neymar fait ce qu'elle veut
bravo marine
c'était arrivé et voilà